Translator: Monica Migliavacca
Reviewer: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
(Music: "Interpassion")
Hi, my name is I am
the one that tangles up
consonants and vowels.
I am international.
Hello, how are you?
Hello, how --
Hey! I speak a little bit --
you don't understand,
but I speak a little bit
and I'm sure you are my friend.
You are my friend,
You are my --
I love people.
I think it's great
we're all hugging here,
as we mix our vowels,
and we make the saddle.
I appreciate less the consonants
of those we haven't sounded.
I'm pressing the buzzer;
I am interpassionate.
Interpassion,
Interpassion.
I am interpassionate.
Interpassion,
Interpassion.
I am interpassionate.
(Music)
Good morning.
What's your name?
Do you know Mafalda?
Do you speak Portuguese?
Are you from California?
Made in China,
I love people.
I think it's great
we're all hugging here,
as we mix our vowels,
that are making the saddle.
I appreciate less the consonants
of those we haven't sounded.
I'm pressing the buzzer;
I am interpassionate.
Interpassion,
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
OK.
Before leaving you guys
with more talks
with better English than mine --
(Laughter)
I would like to see you dance.
And especially a section of your body ...
your hips.
(Laughter)
Alright?
OK, you know your pelvis
is the center of your body
and this is the intersection
that makes you really strong, alright?
(Laughter)
OK, so it's super easy.
We're going to roll our hips together, OK?
So please stand up.
(Laughter)
It's really easy.
You're just going to have
to roll your hips like that.
(Music: "Ba$$in")
Ready?
(Music)
I'd like to kiss that boy
but I don't know how to tell him.
Teach me, teach me,
teach me, teach me,
I'd like to hit on that boy
last time I chased him away.
Show me, show me,
show me, show me.
OK!
Start with making eyes at him.
Start with saying he is cute.
Then you to have to roll your hips,
roll your hips,
roll your hips.
I'd like to dance with him,
like I were his partner.
Teach me, teach me,
teach me, teach me.
I'd like to make him fall in love with me,
as he's looking at my back.
Show me, show me, show me.
Start with making eyes at him.
Start with saying he is cute.
Then you have to roll your hips,
roll your hips,
roll your hip.
You have to roll your hips.
roll your hips,
You have to roll your hips,
You've to roll, roll, roll, roll, roll
roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll
OK!
(Music)
The weekend in Rome,
I have to roll my hips.
While I'm eating an apple,
Whenever I see a man,
I have to roll my hips.
roll my hips, roll my hips.
(Music)
(Clapping)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Cheering)
Thank you so much.
(Applause)
Thank you.